what is going on everybody and welcome
back to part three of our deep learning
with Python and pine torch tutorials in
this tutorial we are going to be
actually building our neural network and
at least really basically explaining how
we pass data and then in the next
tutorial we'll actually train the neural
network so in the previous tutorial we
actually got our data kind of explained
things like normalizing and balancing
and stuff like that and now we're going
to actually build the model itself so in
order for us to do that let me make a
new cell here and we're gonna call this
class or actually we're gonna make a
couple of new imports so we want to
import torch import torch NN as an N and
then we're going to import torch n n dot
and then dot functional as F so the way
I understand this is most things are
kind of in both of these these versions
of pine torch torch MN is more of like
your object-oriented programming and
then torch and n dot functional is more
of just like functions and in general
we're going to be writing
object-oriented programming PI torch but
there's going to be times where you
actually just want to run a specific
function so you'll see what I mean but
in general these two libraries are
interchangeable so if it exists in n n
it exists in functional and so on and
just keep in mind that like with
functional you have to always like pass
parameters whereas like with n n it
would just you would initialize things
right and so some things to my knowledge
don't actually exist in both but anyways
most code that I've seen ends up using
both in theory I think you could write
everything as a function in PI torch but
I'm not sure why you would but anyway
I'm not a PI torch expert but basically
these two things are very very similar
and depending on exactly what you're
trying to build you might use something
from just an N or something from the
functional but anyways carrying on so
now now we'll build our neural network
so we're gonna say class capital n net
it is going to inherit from n n dot
module and then we're going to say
define
in its self and we are going to first
initialize an end module so we're gonna
say super init and if you don't know
what this does basically all this does
is like super corresponds to n n dot
module and all this is doing is running
the initialization for n n dot module as
well as whatever else we happen to put
in in it so when you inherit you inherit
like the methods and attributes so long
as they weren't set and in it I suppose
anyways you inherit at least the methods
and but the thing is the initialization
method is not run so if you want the
initialization method to run of your
parent class that you're inheriting from
you run super init if that's fuzzy to
you for any reason go to the text-based
version this tutorial I show a couple of
examples with classes and importing or
not importing inheriting so it should
clear it up there but if you have
further questions feel free to make a
comment or ask in the discord so let me
do I guess I'm trying to decide what I
think we'll just start defining layers
there's something else I want to talk
about here in general but first we'll
define our layers so in our init method
this is where we're going to just define
we're just going to define the the fully
connected layers to the neural network
and then in another method we actually
define how data passes through so what
I'm gonna say is self dot fc-1 so f c
stands for fully connected and then the
one is just our first fully connected
layer so we're gonna say self dot fully
connected 1 equals n n dot and then
we're gonna say linear and this is going
to take basically you've got input and
then output to each layer so the input
is quite literally our images now I
happen to know the images when flattened
are 784 but you might not so where does
this number come from and this is kind
of one of my complaints with both tensor
flow and pi torch docks is sometimes
they like throw these numbers and it's
like whoa where did that come from
and they like half explain but then they
miss certain things so especially when
we get to the combo
Ellucian allure network will point that
out again but anyways 784 is 28 times 28
because our images are 28 by 28 images
and we can't pass the image instead we
passed the the the flattened image so
you can think of pixels there like rows
right so you've got rows of pixels and
when we flatten those what we're doing
is you got your first row then your
second rows down here well we actually
take that second row we put it over here
so so eventually all of the rows just
make a flat row of pixels so that's what
we refer to generally as flattened so
the input will be a flattened 28 by 28
what's the output well our target here
is to make a three layers of sixty-four
neurons for our hidden layers so the
output will be 64 so for every fully
connected layer we're going to have
input and the input is whatever is
coming into this to this layer so in
this case the input is is the actual
input layer which happens to be the
flattened image the output can be
whatever we want so we could say this if
we wanted but we're we're going with 64
so finally the next thing is n n dot
linear this just means fully connected
is just a flat simple you might also
when we do a convolutional neural
network it'll be n n calm and so on so
so cool I think I've described
everything there so now we're gonna say
pasta pasta and then we'll do one more
pasta so then we're gonna say 2 3 4 so
keep in mind though that certain things
have changed when we go from image to
actual code because this kind of this is
this is the extent of our input layer
right and this number here is kind of
the extent of our hidden layer the
hidden layers are almost in between
these calls or something but anyways
fully connected to takes in 64 because
the previous layer output 64 so this one
has to take in 64 but but now what it
outputs we could pick anything we want
I'm gonna go with 64 though so that
means layer 3 has to take in 64 again we
could output anything we want
go is 64 again so this final layer 4
takes in 64 but we said this was a 3 by
64 so you got 64 64 64 and then this is
our output layer so I'm gonna say 10
where does 10 come from we have 10
classes right we've got 0 1 2 3 4 all
the way to 9 so this is our our output
layer only has 10 neurons cool so that
is our init method it's done we actually
could define our network now so we could
say net equals capital M net and then we
can print net cool so we get to see this
because we get some special methods from
module so what might happen though if we
forgot super init right so part of
learning to work with any of the deep
learning libraries is getting used to
seeing some of the errors and working
through them so if we ran this we would
get the following attribute error cannot
assign module before module that init
call this is not the most helpful error
in the world you would have no idea what
the heck that means but it means you
forgot your super init now normally it
wouldn't be commented out right you
would you wouldn't have even had that
line there so it wouldn't be totally
obvious now I'm sure if you google this
you might find the answer but yeah so as
I think about common errors that you
might hit I'll try to show them but for
the most part you can google them or you
can post a comment or join the discord
and ask cool so continuing along so
we've defined our layers but what we
don't have is any paths for data to take
through these layers so a simple neural
network is what's referred to as a
feed-forward neural network it means
data passes in one direction it just
goes one side to the other side nothing
fancy so uh for our for our for
feed-forward it's a lot of f-words for
feed-forward we're gonna say define
forward and I'm gonna make some space
here
and what we're going to say here is self
and then the input is X so the input is
the data this is the the actual method
that defines how the data will flow
through our network you know we could
have called these layers anything we
wanted
we just said fc-1 2 3 4 but if we wanted
we could actually attempt it would fail
because this is 64 but we could attempt
to actually start by passing data
through fully connected 4 again it's not
gonna work because this size that fully
connected 4 is expecting is a 28 by 28
so it wouldn't work out but we could if
we change this to be 28 by 28 but the
order that we've defined these layers is
irrelevant
just for the record so how do we want
data to pass through here this is the
cool thing about pi torch that if you're
just starting out if never worked with
any other library is going to be
probably lost on you but you get to
choose anything you want so we're gonna
define something pretty simple we're
just gonna say X as it passes through
we're gonna say first X passes through
fully connected 1 so we're just say self
dot FC 1 X that's it and then we're
gonna do the same thing we're just gonna
say hey X is gonna pass through all the
layers right so we're safe up up up and
then we'll say 2 3 4 so x equals fully
connected X so it redefines X and then
we pass it again and then we pass it
again and then we pass it again in
theory you could embed like all this
stuff it would be like one really long
line who'd be so ugly but you could do
it and then return X so in theory I mean
this would work this would run you could
pass data
it probably won't learn why won't it
learn because data won't be scaled
properly most likely why won't it be
scaled properly we forgot our activation
function but you wouldn't I don't think
it would error to be honest with you I'm
pretty sure we could run this and we
could attempt to adjust weights and
biases and stuff like that but it's not
gonna work out well because we don't
have an activation function so what
we're gonna say instead is we're gonna
pass capital F dot rel you which stands
for rectified linear this is our
activation function so we're gonna run
literally activation function over
entire layer but but just remember this
is part of the help earnest of Pi torch
I've never seen anybody do it but in
theory you you could have I think
different activation functions per
neuron I've never seen it done I can't
imagine why one would do that but that's
possible especially if you made such a
large because I'm just getting way ahead
of things
never mind anyways rectified linear is
the activation function if you forget
what the activation function is this is
whether or not the neuron is firing like
the human brain right so you know neural
networks kind of came from trying to
model brains the brain however as far as
I as far as science knows is really more
of a stepper function the neuron is
either firing or it's not firing in the
case of most most activation functions
it's not a stepper function it's a
sigmoid so it's a range between zero and
one but regardless of what activation
function it is it keeps the outputs of
these layers from just just exploding
into these like crazy numbers it can
still happen especially when we go to
like compute gradients and loss and
stuff like that these explosions can
still occur but we do everything we can
to try to not have these magnificent
explosions so and if that doesn't make
sense to you
don't worry we will continue ratcheting
up and you'll soon learn about loss
explosion so so okay so we want to
actually run this on every single layer
so in fact I'm just going to copy and
paste again so first and two three and
actually we don't want to run that on
four we just actually want to pass the
data we'll just pass it just so
everything's nice and explicit so for
mmm so for these like three layers we're
and keep in mind the activation function
kind of runs on on this side right it
doesn't run on the input data so that's
being run on this 64 this 64 this 64 but
then on this 10 we're not actually
running anything on those nerve
yet we don't want to run rectified
linear here because that's not the
actual task again the neural network
doesn't really know anything about
anything so when we talk about
optimizers and back propagation and all
this stuff
you'll I'll bring this up and I'll show
you price and beautiful imagery but the
thing to keep in mind is the neural
network really is pretty stupid like
it's not actually the smartest thing
ever it's just when you combine all
these things that just can do amazing
things it's like ants or something right
like a lot of little basic stuff can do
really complicated things but on this
fully mystic output layer we don't
really want to have rectified linear
because that doesn't really make sense
instead what we want is some sort of
function that constrains to what we
actually want and what we actually want
is only one of these neurons to be fully
fired right our goal like let's say
we've got 10 output I don't really want
to write it but let's say we've got cats
dogs and humans right we want act
outputs like cat dog human let's say
zero zero one we would want our output
layer if we passed a human we would want
it to say zero zero one right that is
our goal these two are off this one is
fully on but we would also say this
would be acceptable right so if it was
like 78% human and then 0.2 to dog I
don't remember what order I said things
were but anyways we want a distribution
like that so when you're working with
something that's like a multi-class so
if it it's not a regression algorithm
where we're trying to like predict some
sort of range you can do regression with
neural networks that's just not what
we're talking about right now what we're
talking about is we've got multiple
classes and what we really want is a
probability distribution on the output
so for a probability distribution we're
going to use log softmax so kind of like
when we talk later about our loss
there's different losses that you might
use optimizer generally everyone uses
the same optimizer like we do with
rectal like with your hidden layers
pretty much everybody uses rectified
linear for the optimizer pretty much
uses the same optimizer but it's when
you have different types of what you
want is the output this is where things
kind of change so with multi class
usually softmax works so what we're
gonna do instead is we're going to apply
a soft max to this X so we'll just throw
that into our return statement so we
return f dot log underscore softmax X
and then we have this other thing that
we have to throw in here which is the
dimension on which we want to apply
softmax now for an output layer that is
of the shape that our output layer is
which will always be flat if we're doing
things this way with linear layers you
just you just assume it's always gonna
be dim one but what is this
so dimension equals one is I believe
similar two axes so if you're coming
from like numpy or pandas you can kind
of think of it like axes I think I could
be totally mistaken but dim one just me
it's like what which thing is the the
probability distribution that we want to
sum to one so in this case we're going
to be passing batches of data so the
output layer will be a batch of tensor
distributions now what do we want the
probability what do we want this
probability of distribution to be a
distribution of I don't know anyways
what do we want to sum to one basically
it's not all of the batches right so
like all the batches aren't the
probability distribution we care about
we care about the classes themselves so
this will be a batch of tensors so if we
said dim zero we would be like
distributing across the batches so dim
one is we're distributing across the
actual output layer the output layer
tensors so anyways dim one I probably
did a terrible job explaining that but
like I said you can think of it like an
axis or just say dim one and don't worry
about it to be honest because I can
imagine you're gonna change that I don't
even know what the like the default
value might be dim one I really don't
know
anyway cool so that's our neural network
and let's go ahead and run that make
sure whoops what good thing that would
have been a problem let's go and run
that okay cool so it looks like
everything sort of works let's actually
pass some data through the neural
network though so what we're going to do
is first we need some data so we're
gonna say x equals x equals let's say
let's try to mimic an actual image that
we might have so we're gonna say capital
x equals torch dot brand and then we're
going to say it's a 28 by 28 cool let's
just look at it real quick okay so I'm a
my nose is super itchy
okay so that's pretty meaningless to us
but yeah those are some random values
then we could in theory passes to our
neural network but recall actually let's
pass it let's see what happens because
it's I think it will yell at us let's
just say output equals m-net and then
we're literally going to pass X this is
probably going to err yes so we come
down here and we see here that we have
it some sort of size mismatch okay so it
says 28 by 28 so and then the input is a
784 so again it has to be flattened
first so what is one thing that we could
say well we could say x equals x dot
view and then we'll just say 28 times 28
run that run this again and we're like
dude what the heck right and again we
get some sort of error that if you're
new to this you're gonna not understand
what the hey this thing is talking about
so so instead what we have to do and in
fact I don't think I'll get away with
this but let's try this
and just past it I'm just curious if I
get away with it I don't think I would
but no so you have to format things
exactly how these libraries want them in
this case we're going to say we actually
want to view as a negative 128 by 28 let
me run that make sure that works it sure
does the negative one just specifies
that this is a these will be this this
input will be of an unknown shape we
also should be able to get away with one
by 28 by 28 we do and in fact let me
just output it let me just paste it real
quick cool so so either way whether you
do negative 1 or 1 you still get the
exact same answer why is this because
this actually is a 1 by 28 by 28 but in
theory this could be many more right so
you could have a 3 by 28 by 28 or
something like that right like so your
this will be whatever your batch size is
so we can say negative 1 because we're
basically just saying it's of any size
just be prepared for any amount of data
to be passed through don't worry about
it it doesn't matter and so this just is
an array that is of any size or a tensor
rather but then we just pass it through
and then was this these are the actual
predictions right so this is the
prediction for a 0 1 2 3 4 and so on it
just goes on now there's a couple of
things that we didn't quite do we
haven't like initialized weights
randomly we're also the first few passes
of information through your network are
going to be worthless like they're not
actually meaningful in any way but now
you've seen we passed data through the
neural network and we got a return now
what we have to talk about is what do we
do with it right so you see Grady or
grab FN that stands for gradient
function and when we pass information
through what we're gonna do next is
calculate how far off were we so what
was the number that we passed who knows
we don't I don't actually know
but we're gonna say is the goal let's
say it wasn't one it would be this this
here there so hopefully this was the Arg
max and humans we think about things in
terms of whether or not you were right
or wrong but there's degrees right if
you're like slightly if you think it's a
one but you're not really sure right
that's different than if you're like
100% positive that's a one well if it's
not a one you're way more wrong in the
second case than the first case and
that's important if we want to slowly
adjust and figure out how we can be
right more often so cool so I think
that's probably all I really want to
talk about up to this point I don't
really think there's anything else that
I want to show here so a quick shout out
to my channel members who have been with
me now for six months half a year that's
a long time Howard Liang fidget career
ocean Cove cheeky buns frank lloyd jr.
in Mohammad Al Moore thank you guys very
much for your support it allows me to do
what I love to do so thank you guys very
much okay so that's it for now I feel
like there was one more thing I wanted
to talk about and I honestly don't
remember
hopefully I remember at some point but
yeah there was something really
important that I wanted to tell you guys
and I just it's eating a me excited
there's something I want to say can't
remember I've remembered what it was now
I gotta edit things okay so this will be
way more important like down the line
but one thing to think about is this
here this forward function that we've
done especially if you're coming from
any other learning library you can do
fancy things here so you could yeah you
could say if weather equals sunny right
or something like that do these things
at this at this point else right do some
other things right so you can actually
you can throw logic into this forward
method to do whatever you want so you
can actually come up with some really
advanced models and yes you can do this
in other languages you can branch out
and do fancy things and you can do it
but it's way more challenging
with pine torch it's just that simple
and the gradients are automatically
calculated
that's really cool I don't know if we'll
actually I'd love to come up with like a
really cool example where we actually do
that one example that I always think
about or at least that I thought about
when we when I figured out you could do
that is like the Python plays Grand
Theft Auto so this is an agent that
needs to be able to drive really well
but also do things like if it's on foot
figure out how to steal a car or maybe
do some shooting or something like that
but the primary task of that neural
network at first is to just analyze and
process imagery so the first few layers
could be image processing layers that
are going to be the same whether you're
driving we were on foot or whatever and
then the subsequent layers could be very
specific to the task that thing is doing
so think like robotics or you know other
things in general where the first few
layers that the general tasks is always
the same and then the next few layers
could be very specific to exactly what
the task is so anyway that was the thing
that I meant to bring up and I kept
forgetting and I knew there was
something I knew there was something ok
that's it for now if you can't tell I'm
really excited about that if you're not
excited then you haven't worked with
other libraries in that is much more
challenging so ok see you guys in the
next video